[Music]
who reject nation I'm Greg Elbe we're
gonna watch the trailer for city of lies
the movie where I hunt down the killers
of Tupac and Biggie you know for the
location man $100,000 to punch him in
the face or for him to punch me I forget
I have a temper now picture the day
shoutout to John mini John mini is a
hardcore sports guy lives in Albany New
York we need a Google hangout with this
dude I really have no clue why he
watches our channel but he's an athletic
friendly guy been married for less than
a year John mini I hope one day you can
become that famous sportscaster you hope
to become and despite the fact that
you're a trump supporter they say to
keep your friends close but your enemies
closer and that way I can you know I can
tickle your beard you got a nice beard
oh yeah like Billy Goat if there's
anything and say about you you have made
us hardcore Trump supporters even though
we never talked about it yeah okay
anybody we love you
trailer 20 years ago and you would have
lead detective out the big small case
right
I'm a journalist why this case all point
to you
a murder like that only goes unsolved if
the police don't to solve
I've seen the workbook you having
suspects 20-plus years and not one of us
you guys hearing to pass uterus were
hired by these arms for us we didn't
have to kill the Fox Point simple
morning the wicked wolf connection
between carpet Biggie's work deep woods
girl
[Music]
Wow why did you redact LAPD's
connectional records cannot investigate
[Music]
investigations that stick away from
blood-stained streets every day
[Music]
I have no idea put the LAPD's capable of
we are distancing ourselves from the
story got what I need
[Music]
[Music]
there's only one way
[Laughter]
whoo-hoo that looks pretty intense man
it looks intense yeah looks like a David
Ayer movie me yes
true detective meets zodiac yeah yeah
one of those like true crime gritty
street oh yeah exactly what I said well
I like that now Johnny Depp has gone
into this later stage in his career
where he can kind of play this one kind
of tired guy but we're gonna find a good
place to put yeah maybe like a
supporting actor to play off of he's a
lot more energy than you yeah that's he
looks great in this too I think both of
them look great yeah I mean I heard
those stories of Johnny Depp like like
belligerently drunk once again on set
and like causing a violent stir in terms
of what we're looking at in this movie
in terms of the context of just this
trailer the last time I thought he did a
great job was the movie Black Mass there
was another true story it was a real
life character that he played and I
think that when he plays a real life
character he has a lot more respect does
a better job because of the fact that
it's based on a true character I can see
that so he does what he can I'm sure
he's got like you know videos to go off
of to really embody those characters
external things to really draw from he's
not doing like weird Johnny Depp boy
stuff but it's oh it feels like a
different dude I was watching this and
it's like yeah because of the fame of
Johnny Depp I'm aware of him at the same
time though I feel like I can just buy
this dude as a character yeah especially
in the pace in the and the structure of
the movie I'm sure that the you know the
breathing room a lot I could come to
definitely you can still catch the
glimmers of greatness from his
performances and so I think this is a
very relevant movie I mean this has been
going on for years and years and years
but I feel like a lot has been coming to
spotlight in the past couple years oh
yeah especially in regards to like LAPD
and everything hip-hop is the biggest
kind of music around and these are like
two titans and we're also debate Chinese
the stall Joe
but there's also like you know people
have been hotly debating like the
relevancy of Tupac and like figures like
the old heads and stuff like that yeah
and you also have so much distrust for
the police and so much police connection
being exposed like yeah there's a lot
that's relevant here it's an interesting
story of this one detective because I
never caught the killer
that's what I meant by like Zodiac
especially because the force would occur
character attire mind you have Jake
Gyllenhaal being a journalist and zodiac
so they never caught the killer but it
led to uncovering something much bigger
a much bigger corruption going on the
fact that it's spanning so many years
you get to kind of watch this guy aged
and deteriorate over the course of this
long-ass investigation it sounds intense
and it looks like it's gonna be a rather
gritty crime thriller that'll be
probably embedded in its performances
yeah it looks like a really tense movie
yeah that's the main sort of flavor I
got off this is tension and suspense
even because there's a bit of a sinister
vibe on this and yeah I kind of agree
I'll especially like a cop mystery where
it's not necessarily that we're gonna
figure out the answer to this one
problem but we're gonna find some of a
whole mess of other problems attached to
it and that could be really light fee
and really kind of real in in a sense
yeah so I'm excited to see them take it
on and I'm excited to see the pairing of
the Johnny Depp and Forest Whitaker
because they're both great actors you
know I just hope this movie is gonna be
able to do this in a contained format
because I'm sure it's gonna want to
touch on themes of corruption in LAPD
I'm sure it's gonna touch on racism
themes it's gonna have to touch on a lot
of things but then the day it's like
what are we really gonna show up here
for I think what the trailer song you
want is the intensity of the situation
the thriller of uncovering a mysterious
plot sometimes a film like this you try
to handle too many things at once I feel
like at the end of the day if they keep
it contained within its characters the
film will be just fine great post Labor
Day fumble all right what do you guys
think of this trailer it's Johnny Depp
gonna win your heart back and then crush
it again you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell because subscribe buttons don't
really work hey check us on patreon
full-length TV show reactions music
video coverage weekly Q&A is with
love to have you become at a tirana deck
to be